hi I'm Elle and I play Aurora aka
Sleeping Beauty and Maleficent mistress
of evil hi I'm Shirley Jo I play Connell
hi I'm Sam Riley and I'm blankie about
hey young harris i played prince philip
and we're gonna take a BuzzFeed quiz to
find out which Disney villain we are
[Music]
first things first
how would your friends describe you
caring ambitious honest fabulous
charming confidence my friends would
honestly know describe things they say
it's what I'm saying careless you really
yeah I'm gonna say caring as well
because I like to think I ain't even I'm
gonna say honest pick a loyal sidekick a
bird a dog a sheep a dragon a snake or a
cat
you got to pick a burger I think about
dragon we're doing a dog a new dog is
like yeah cuz my dog wouldn't forgive me
if I didn't
yeah pick a Disney Princess you don't
want to curse you what does that mean it
was pretty brutal Mulan Tiana Belle
Rapunzel Snow White
Pocahontas it doesn't mean you want to
curse all the others because every other
it means your life saving one of them
I'm gonna say Mulan because she looked
she in the photo she looks really angry
so I wouldn't want a cursor cuz she
would stab me I'm gonna go with Belle
cuz I think that was my little sister's
favorite okay I'm gonna say Rapunzel
because she threw down that hair
Pocahontas
pick a Disney song to rock out to a
karaoke I just can't wait to be king
from The Lion King be our guest from
Beauty and the Beast I'll make a man
anew you from Milan Milan you got a
friend in me Toy Story well I'm not from
Lady in the trap zero to hero Hercules
who sang you got a friend in me again
you got a friend
I'm gonna random here but I like running
but I never be our guest
yeah it's a good one I'm gonna go I just
can't wait to be king I'm gonna do I'll
make a man out of you choose another
Disney villain to hang out with Meredith
Blake from The Parent Trap Queen naki
sir from enchanted the White Witch from
The Lion the Witch and the Wardrobe
Louise Walker from holes Oh when he
Sanderson from hocus pocus or Thanos
from Avengers endgame I just wanna hang
out with Jill this way to us the light
which Meredith always grinded monkey is
minute really from the pan truck
remember I think you left this and will
be jealous if I hung out with any of the
other ones so I'm gonna go with Thanos I
think yeah tilda swinton I think yeah
pick a bed that makes you want to fall
into a deep sleep I think the first one
it's like white fluffy looks nice no I
don't do those I would do the first one
yeah I mean oh just looks the comfiest
how do you the second one a of the
wooden bed is loose let the lowest to
the ground that appeals to me if I can't
explain it
I could definitely fall asleep on the
hammocks I'm gonna go get out finally
what is your one vice it's so sweet do
they think I'm I only have one and none
of them are there yes I make up sleep
caffeine money shoes and social media
I'm going with shoes yeah I'm gonna go
with coffee as well makes me coffee
oh my god I got
you have a tough exterior but deep deep
deep deep down I'm spirit extremely
caring and there's nothing you wouldn't
do for the ones you love
I actually got Cruella developed it was
the better low bed there's something
yeah you look good in you know you turn
heads everywhere you go because of the
energy you emit and and the clothes on
your back we both got the same same one
with scar from like extremely smart and
Devesh the charming which altogether is
a combination that makes people admire
you and feel you just a little bit yeah
thank you
[Music]